merci monsieur mamère la parole est à
monsieur jean lassalle sur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
violemment et sauvagement frappé notre
pays notre peuple d'abord le président
le parlement ont réagi d'une manière qui
a impressionné le monde
une fois de plus et ça a été après le
terrible moment un grand vent d'espoir
faut ce geek aussi ceux qui se
considèrent dans un monde libre
la constitution actuelle nous a permis
de franchir des moments bien difficiles
il n'est pas jusqu'aux années 60 elle
permet de résoudre des problèmes que
nous tentons aujourd'hui de résoudre
d'une manière qui est pas adaptée à la
situation
je crois que le problème n'est pas là
évitant d'apporter de la confusion à la
confusion de la peur à la peur et dans
un pays qui est aujourd'hui tourneboulé
éditant de l'entrée du doigt ne serait
ce que dans les fantasmes les plus fous
des communautés qui sans la france c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pense que
nous aurons était beau et fidèle à notre
histoire nous devons le redevenir
et monsieur le président de la
république se grandirait style pire il
reviendrait au niveau il a été il ya
quelques semaines
en prenant l'initiative de mettre un
terme à ce débat il ne nous apporte rien
il nous a faibli merci